well it happened in Georgia and we
talked about it we covered the Alabama
anti-abortion law earlier this week and
now Missouri has passed another one of
these absurdly extreme anti-abortion
bills and this bill passed in the
Missouri Senate and what it would do is
ban abortion starting at eight weeks of
pregnancy period remember many women
don't even know that they're pregnant
until five weeks into pregnancy six
weeks into pregnancy there are obviously
exceptions that go even beyond that but
it's it's very common that until five or
six weeks into pregnancy a woman may not
know that she's pregnant and this bill
would set a limit for legal abortions at
eight weeks the bill now goes back to
the house for one more vote before it
would be sent to the Republican Missouri
governor Mike parson for a vote into law
and parson is expected to sign it now
there are some important differences
between this law and others that have
been passed one is that this is a law
that in its most extreme form would be
triggered by the overturning of roe v
wade and otherwise has some slightly
less insane provisions and limits in it
in terms of exceptions there are
exceptions in this law for medical
emergencies but like the Alabama law no
exceptions for rape no exceptions for
incest either and as far as punishing
doctors and/or mothers mothers of women
who have abortions would not be
prosecuted and doctors who perform
abortions after eight weeks could be
faced with five to 15 years in prison so
once again it's not so much about this
law specifically although looking at
what it is that they're doing and the
provisions that are and aren't part of
each law is important this is all part
of the bigger plan that we've been
telling you now about for months and in
more detail for a couple of weeks and in
more significant detail in the last
three or four shows this week this is
all part of the bigger plan to get one
of these laws struck down by an
immediate by a lower federal court and
then use the appeal process to try to
get it to the Supreme Court
to really get a opportunity that maybe
has not been
around for decades - seriously stifle
abortion nationally either through a
sort of implicit conflict with roe v
wade or in some scenarios by actually
getting roe v wade overturned although
as i explained on yesterday's show
overturning roe v wade in and of itself
is not necessary for these laws to have
an appeal process ultimately to the
supreme court that could result in the
significant limiting of abortion
federally oh not not federally at and in
multiple states as a result of a federal
court's ruling and it's important to
know that you know missouri already has
one of the strictest anti-abortion laws
in the country they've got a 72 hour
mandatory waiting period there's only
one abortion clinic in the entire state
so when you step back and we see that we
had alabama earlier this week we've
we've already seen georgia Kentucky
Mississippi and Ohio moving forward with
abortion bans once fetal cardiac
activity can be detected which again is
right around the sixth week of pregnancy
North Dakota and Iowa tried similar
things so far those have been struck
down in court
the whole point here is passed something
so extreme that it has to be seen as a
conflict with roe v wade which will in
the immediate get a court to strike it
down which will over the medium to long
term open it to appeal all the way up to
the Supreme Court which Donald Trump has
had the great fortune if you are on his
side of being able to a port appoint
some very conservative justices to and
this is going to be a huge fight and
it's yet another reminder of how
ignorant that idea was that Trump and
Hillary are going to be the same you
know what if it's not going to be the
person I really want it almost doesn't
matter whether it's Trump or Hillary
because they're going to be the same
well listen I hope anyone who had that
idea now realizes how absurdly
ridiculous and wrong it was Hillary
would not have put two lunatics on the
Supreme Court who would have systemic
Lee endangered abortion rights across
the country
and reinvigorated what we are seeing at
the state level now meant to really
repress abortion rights nationally
Hillary would not have considered
military action against Venezuela and in
Iran maybe in other places as some
people like to argue but the idea that
they were both equally likely to get us
into military conflicts come on I mean
there's a very long list here of
countries that Trump has considered
military action against there is a very
long list of issues on which in practice
not in theory but in practice Trump and
Hillary would have been very different
and I hope nobody Falls for that
nonsense going into 2020 because we are
seeing that the impact is real the
impact is on people this is not
theoretical political science this is
day-to-day affecting people's lives if
you love learning new things you
probably want to check this out the
david pakman show today is sponsored by
Skillshare and we're giving you two
entire months of free access to
Skillshare when you click the link
underneath this video Skillshare is a
vibrant online learning community
offering more than 25,000 video classes
on just about anything you can think of
get better at playing an instrument
learn to use Photoshop how to edit
videos they have classes on drawing
painting business cooking nutrition
personal productivity and I'm not even
really scratching the surface I recently
took a great class on introductory
watercolour painting I'm still not good
but I am learning and you can access the
entire library of fun easy to use online
courses for free for two months by using
the link underneath this video two
months of learning something that's
totally new to you something you want to
get better at something you already love
or you can get ahead in your career by
learning new skills that will help you
at your job I've gotten a ton out of it
Pat has taken some courses that he's
found really valuable and I think you'll
love it to get started for free by
clicking the link under this video